begleitet von massiven vorwürfen des
wahlbetrugs ist russlands präsident
wladimir putin mit dreiviertel mehrheit
im amt bestätigt worden
putin kommt prognosen zufolge auf fast
74 prozent der stimmen die opposition
und die wahlbeobachter gruppe golos
prangern massive verstöße bei der wahl
an
wir heute auf bronze zum einen geht es
um das vollstopfen der wahlurnen das
internet ist voll von videos von
überwachungskameras die zeigen wie leute
einen packen stimmzettel in die wahlurne
stecken das passiert überall im land
diese bilder einer überwachungskamera
aus einem wahllokal bei moskau sollen
zeigen wie wahlhelfer eine urne mit
stimmzetteln vollstopfen dass beobachter
team von kreml kritiker navalny ist auf
noch mehr unregelmäßigkeiten gestoßen
es hat nach eigenen angaben mehr als
33.000 beobachter in wahlbüros in ganz
russland entsandte auch trend ist das
massive herankarren von wählern in
russen
wir haben berichte darüber aus allen
regionen das organisierte herankarren
von wählern ist wie bestechung sie
werden zur stimmabgabe an die wahllokale
gefahren
aber man hätte putin als einziger
gefährlich werden können er war jedoch
wegen einer gerichtlichen verurteilung
von der wahl ausgeschlossen worden
anderen kandidaten waren von vornherein
chancenlos